fifteen years since the u.s. launched
his operation in Iraq the country is far
from peace and stability
his recent anti-government protests
showed yet the careers of those in the
US media who proclaimed the invasion
will be a good thing for the country are
still going strong katieb Maupin has
more back in 2003 when the USA invaded
Iraq mainstream media dropped the ball
there were no weapons of mass
destruction and the US troops weren't
greeted as glorious liberators either
now 15 years later the same journalist
that had us believing back then
alright the same thing now take Bill
Kristol editor of The Weekly Standard
back in 2003 he had us convinced that
Saddam Hussein was on the verge of using
his WMDs against the world no one
questions furthermore the basic facts
about Saddam Hussein's weapons programs
now he was very wrong but that did not
stop his career not by a long shot
in fact he's still the editor of the
Weekly Standard which ironically has
been named a fact-checker by Facebook he
comes on television all the time
promoting US military interventions just
like the old days what do you do when a
brutal dictator wants to fight to death
what you do is he sin his death hasten
his departure and I think we could do
much more to do them if we don't just do
a pinprick attack and I think this has
been senator McCain's concern and the
concern of all of us Hawks but a serious
attack now another voice in the media
chorus backing US military intervention
against Saddam Hussein was Judith Miller
Judith Miller writing for the New York
Times had us convinced that Saddam
Hussein was trying to make an atomic
bomb it's Iraq's pursuit of nuclear
weapons however that is at the top of
the administration's list of worries and
forms a key part of its case for a
military campaign to overthrow mr.
Hussein in 2015 she admitted that she
was wrong about her WMD stories now
Judith Miller is on Fox News she's
become a full member of the Council on
Foreign Relations and she's treated as
credible on mainstream media when she
talks about chemical weapons in Syria
the point of this action which is to
restore the red line against the use of
chemical weapons which Bashar Assad
and Russia aided by Russia and Iran have
begun to use with him with impunity and
then there's Sean Hannity the primetime
Fox personality these are his words back
in 2003 this madman who's killed a
million and a half people and gas
children he does it again just like many
of his colleagues Sean Hannity was wrong
about weapons of mass destruction in
Iraq but it hasn't stopped his career
now he's calling for regime change again
this time in Iran let me ask you and you
have helped organize what's happening
today you are in touch with them every
day how do you win a revolution without
weapons and then there was Phil Donahue
he was the lone voice on NBC opposing
the war he lost his show he was fired
now we have a memo explaining why he
would be a difficult public face for NBC
in a time of war he seemed to delight
and present in guests who are anti-war
anti-bush and skeptical of the
administration's motives so we're
learning from our mistakes right
wrong we've still got mainstream media
in the United States pushing unproven
versions of events without firming up
the facts that's okay it has no impact
on the careers of journalists who push a
popular version of events I think if you
just look at the way MSNBC CNN and Fox
cover world affairs and specifically
events around countries you can see that
the decision was intentional because of
the way they frame their coverage no
opposing voices are permitted when it
comes to the u.s. foreign policy and
it's the agenda of the national security
state which makes it what makes this so
dangerous is that American news
consumers believe that they're consuming
news from a free media from private
media channels that this isn't state
media but when private corporate media
channels fill up the screen with former
intelligence and military officials
neoconservatives and figures who are
connected to and
regime change operation in the last
decade and a half is essentially
national security state TV advanced in a
much more insidious way than state TV
could
you